how you can know about the topics that
we will cover
the schedule how to register all of that
information
i will actually share that information
with you so
if you could go with me to our site
called learn learnomicslogic.com and so
for this part of the session i would
like to ask you to actually make sure
that you are registered
so this is the link learn
on xlogic.com so if you could please let
me know
once you have registered on the site
i will show you how to access the
specific
tutorials and the synchronous materials
that you will
leverage throughout the program i will
also briefly demonstrate
how you can access the tbylinfo platform
and try the analysis even in today's
session so you get a sense of what kind
of hands-on
practical activities you will be going
through i will also show you
how to utilize the r code playground
so that you can practice some of the
code that we will be going through
for reporting and for tracking those
variants
and also i will then show you how you
can register
for the full program so please let me
know in the chat once you have been
registered if you're registered already
that's great just let me know in the
chat i will be looking for your answers
so once you are on this page
you need to go to login and on the login
screen
you can either log in you're using your
email address
or create an account right here so i
will
log in using my details
and once you are logged in you will be
seeing
your profile here where you can
understand
how the program actually works in both
asynchronous
mode and synchronous mode so for the
asynchronous mode really you have access
to
a number of different opportunities
for learning different courses we have a
number of different courses that use
data from the public domain and show
steps that you can replicate on your own
and
another section that you will see here
is
programs so the same is available on the
top
menu you can go to courses and search
for courses so we can search here for
example for
sars and you will find this project
right here
covet 19 origin and pathogenesis of
source code
2 or you can search for genomics
and find a course that introduces you to
the basics of genomics
how to align sequences what are
nucleotides what are amino acids what is
multiple sequence alignments
what is variant calling etc you'll also
find here
some course work on coding including
getting
started with bioinformatics in r or in
python
okay so again this is the main area
for you to gain access to some
asynchronous materials and you can
search here most of these courses are
going to include
some basic material that you can get
started with
and then as you are convinced that this
is the right topic
for you the next stage is for you to
find some premium course work that
includes a little bit more hands-on
and a little bit more depth on the
various options for bioinformatics
analysis
and that comes with our starter
subscription so the starter subscription
is really affordable anywhere around the
world it's only ten dollars a month
and for that ten dollars a month you
gain access to all of the coursework
that is available here
even though most of it you could sample
completely free of charge
then we recommend moving on to the next
level which are the programs and so
today we have been speaking about
the source cove ii program so that
program
is going to start on july 12th so if you
search in the program covet 19 genomics
and variant analysis
this is the program that we're going to
be starting now on my screen
you see what it looks like for someone
that is already
registered for the program so let me
introduce
a little bit what this works like or how
this works like
so as you can see we have listed here
the different
sessions they start on july 12th
and you will see the topics listed right
here
with the specific dates for them when
they will take
place and you can actually download all
of this information by clicking
clicking on this icon right here so
you can scroll through and see how we
will go through genomic data analysis
you will see how we will perform
the analysis in r and then you will see
what are the different topics that will
be covered in the different sessions
down here below you will also see some
of the coursework that's going to be
included
and that coursework starts with a course
on introduction to bioinformatics
this is a free course that we recommend
everyone to take
and the course includes some important
information about the applications of
bioinformatics in a variety of domains
so whether you are interested
specifically in source code
2 or you're interested in other topics
like
transcriptomic data analysis metagenomic
data analysis
precision medicine and others you can
actually go through this course
and see the different applications that
will link it to
the next step of what you can do in this
process so after you've sampled some of
those courses you will actually get
a certificate to get that certificate
you need to have you need to
complete all of the sessions that we
have
in the program so there are going to be
10 sessions and
that will come with our point system
that you need to
uh let me empty the caches here that you
need to complete in order to gain the
certificate so the certificate comes
as a collaboration with a
university in haifa which is a
university
that is focused on development of
bioinformatics tools
that it seems somalia that somebody
forgot to upload the certificate here
but it's important to complete this
information
that is presented in the program to gain
that certificate
and then finally what you will find here
is
a slack channel that you can join to be
connected with the mentors
and the community of those that are
participating in the
program and so if you join the program
by the start of the session which is
going to be july 12th
you will have full access to our mentors
and to the other participants and you
will see all of the interaction
happen in live sessions like today
as well as on a slack channel project
dedicated to the community as you can
see here we have different slack
channels for different programs and so
there it's an
effective way to track different
questions and technical issues
as well as to interact personally
one-on-one with those that are
members of this community
in addition to this i want to show you a
little bit about
the bioinformatics toolkit that you will
gain
access to as a part of your registration
so registering for this program will
give you access
to some important pipelines that are
going to be useful
as we go through the different examples
so let me show you what i
mean by that here and by the way
after you have registered you already
have a demo account on this platform
this platform is called t-bioinfo and it
is developed by the tower bioinformatics
research center
so here you can see how using different
types of
pre-made pipelines you'll be able to
understand better
what are the specifics of the logic
behind this analysis so how does that
work
you will gain access to this interface
in the interface we have
informative pop-ups that allow you to
learn about
each step of the analysis including what
type of data we are using what is the
logic behind
each individual step and what are the
specific
outcomes of this step in the whole
process
of analysis so performing these
pipelines together you will learn about
how
the specific types of methods that we
are utilizing
are helping us gain a full result that
we can
analyze in the next step of the program
so once you have this result some of
this result is going to come
as a pdf that you can download and
explore visually
some information is going to be faster
files or even tables that you need to
know how to work with
so to do that i will give you just one
example of what you can do with some of
this information and to do that
let me show you a course called getting
started with bioinformatics in r
so this is a course in r
that will help you take faster files
and tables and learn how to manipulate
them to
produce visual outputs and the important
part of this
is that the practice comes right inside
the browser so
even before you install and configure
all of your libraries you can already
learn the code
and try yourself so for example in this
brief
lesson you will learn about different
libraries to work with
faster files and sequences and you will
see how
the specific steps of this process are
explained very clearly in terms of the
coding
and then you'll be able to try yourself
simply
running this code in the browser itself
and looking at the output so
learning about the code and then knowing
how to perform the analysis itself
gives you the ability to try this and
then you will be given some assignments
that are going to be challenges for you
to address
as you try to write your own code will
help you reestablish
what is the logic but also how to
practically translate that logic
to coding skills in r so the program
itself
will cover these topics from biology to
bioinformatics
to then the application to specific data
sets that we've curated specifically for
this program and will end with your
ability to
perform the full analysis independently
and ultimately for those that are
interested
we also offer this as they transfer into
our research fellowship program
which is a specific program that helps
you analyze the data
and then generate a report that you can
share
with others including writing a full
report
as you go through the project steps and
to help you
do that we actually have a full project
on how you can get started with a
bioinformatics research
project so this project
this course will guide you through the
important steps of
finding a relevant topic by performing
literature review
identifying a data set in the public
repository that you can analyze
and then submit the full project and get
feedback
from our expert community so ultimately
when you go back to your personal
profile you will be able to
track your progress and activity using
our tracker
and the point system you will also be
able to see
what courses you have completed and all
the certificates for each individual
course are going to be available on your
profile as well right here under
certificates
you will also see the progress of the
program and each session that you have
completed so you can also include
certificates for the program
itself and finally you will be able to
follow our process to get a project
completed during this program
and post it under your profile so once
your profile is complete
and you have reached at least 10 000
points by
completing the coursework assigned to
you as a part of this program or
independently
then you will be able to submit a full
project and you first have to learn
about that project submission
and then submit your project as an
example
to all of the people that you would like
to share with
that illustrates how you have performed
this analysis so here
at the bottom of the homepage you will
find some of those examples from our
previous participants
that have completed a project
i think this gives a brief overview of
what the program is going to be about
and hopefully everyone was able to
see the different aspects of the program
curriculum
the way that we will interact and the
different resources that are going to be
included
if you have any questions that would be
happy happy to answer those
at this time
and i do want to recommend for all of
you that are interested in the source
code 2
project we do have that project
available
that you can try out and see
what that content looks like learn about
some of the basics
as you get started kind of setting the
background for the whole
project context and then taking that
forward with
this guided mentor guided program if
you're interested to
learn more and also become proficient in
some of these methods of analysis
how do you access the arc course so all
you need to do is to register
on the omixlogic program platform sorry
and you will see different courses as
they've shown
so you can actually go to the courses
tab
right here and search for r
i'm sorry
search for r
and get started with getting started
with bioinformatics
or if you want more advanced r you can
go to introduction to data science
now several of the projects that you see
here also
include specific codes in r for example
if you go to genomics as i mentioned
you will find here some course work in r
as well
so whenever you see our code that means
that the
course includes some